winning the environmental war will
require a commitment far beyond any
commitment ever made by any society in
the history of man are we able yes are
we willing
that's the unanswered question
today we are faced with a challenge that
calls for a shift in our thinking so
that humanity stops threatening its
life-support system
the oceans are being assaulted by carbon
dioxide plastic pollution illegal
fishing and too much fishing in some
places it's huge and is powerful and
it's big but it's fragile together
citizens of the world we will work to
save our planet
from ourselves there's a place in Baja
California called cabo pulmo 30 years
ago it's fish populations were
completely decimated and then one brave
family decided to prohibit fishing on
their own reef in a single human
generation the fish have come back
spectacularly
the ocean has an extraordinary capacity
to regenerate when it is protected we're
not going to meet this challenge unless
the community of nations comes together
around a single comprehensive global
ocean strategy
Matt official decision a que tiene miedo
es como Aquila lani CA del caño mir
nasir maybe
today I can announce we are taking steps
to create two new marine sanctuaries the
New Zealand government will establish a
six hundred and twenty thousand square
kilometre ocean sanctuary in the comedic
region Kurtis has taken the decision to
fully close all commercial fishing
activities within the Phoenix islands
protected area for more Tennesseans
nursery for the political tarnish of
mathematics come on peace and solace in
every nerve lab become president
National Library Mahina Norway will do
its part of combat marine plastic waste
and micro plastics convolute Amole tena
koe Nanaia do no gobierno esto se puede
hacer Luis impossible
we know what we need to do to address
the threats facing the ocean there's
nothing that we're looking at it doesn't
have a solution
you